before I started playing electric guitar
people just titled my music is folk
music which I thought was bizarre but
now that I don't play as much acoustic
people say it's indie I wanted to learn
about the independent music scene and
the communities where the genre comes
from so I partnered with my friends over
at indie Alaska to show me one Alaska
pirate story
Dwayne Kristofferson is a young musician
born and raised in the last frontier
after making independent music in
Anchorage for years he rose to relative
stardom in 2019 when he won the NPR tiny
desk concert contest so Quinn if I
wanted to make an indie song what
exactly what I do what steps would I
take to make a complete indie song if
you wanted to make an indie song I would
tell you to pick someone you love and
that you want to write about and write a
song about them or a long start there so
question for you Quinn do you think we
should collaborate on a song together
yeah absolutely
let's get it what's doing it I have a
feeling that you know you're just gonna
bring bring something special to the
table okay thank you
they can try much try my darndest to the
indie table that is indeed right while
we work on that song together let's
learn more about the indie music scene
before indeed described a band sound
independent music was just that
independent taking a page from punk
rockers before them in the 70s indie
bands followed the do-it-yourself
details of self-reliance and operating
outside the mainstream music culture
since indie describes the band's outlook
more than a musical style independent
musicians can range from the electronic
soul style of Frank Ocean
to the lyrical and melancholy sounds of
the Smiths
[Music]
and like most John Roos sound and style
is greatly influenced by location to
learn more about the history of the
music scene in Alaska we spoke with kurt
riemann the owner of surreal studios the
oldest recording studio in anchorage
every piece of music in Alaska's
independent music there there's no label
supporting anything in Alaska so the
people that stay here are people that
are very fiercely independently Alaska
Knights who take whatever it is they're
working on whether it's folk or punk or
rock or electronic or whatever and put
their own independent spin on it
in another 50 to 100 years it's going to
be seen as the folk music of the time
when acknowledges that his sudden rise
to fame might be considered an anomaly
in the independent music industry I kind
of like skipped a lot of steps person
wins this contest and then they're like
in this like world also which is I think
unique other indie musicians they make a
record do-it-yourself upload it and then
maybe a record label gets hold of it and
it's like oh we you know will like this
we'll release this and then they kind of
get their cert from that
before I was working full-time job and
my music was solely kind of like this
therapy thing and my songs are kind of
crushing in that way and I think now
that I've been able to give my full self
and like my work hours to my music I've
been able to like experience it use it
in in all sorts of different emotions
and I I didn't before so I think it's
definitely changed all the things songs
with dark somber lyrics are common all
over mainstream music right now just
look at the popularity of musicians like
Lana Del Rey and post Malone and
recently when Billie Eilish made history
at the 2020 Grammys by collecting six of
the seven top awards with her album that
she recorded in her brother's bedroom in
their family home clearly people are
drawn to this style in the indie music
scene a DIY style of recording music is
common Quinn told us he once recorded a
song by putting a sock over a microphone
indie music also tends to be more
sonically adventurous or experimental
some independent bands like Neutral Milk
Hotel sound purposefully raw with pity
vocals and over modulated instrumental
sections
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Quinn tell me about your your time
when you enter the tiny desk competition
and you want what was that like best
things ever having me for sure like
seriously amazing
we entered last year and I say we cause
it's like a community affair like making
a video and putting her together and
putting it out
[Music]
[Music]
it was just crazy I'm seeing tune up
this guitar looking at you Bob because I
don't know if you know this but when you
called me and you told me you won I got
off the phone I thought hang I should
buy a guitar legit did not have one but
that's Anchorage that's the music
community there everyone just borrowed
me their stuff long-term it was unreal
[Music]
everybody hot has to hit tiny destiny oh
my it's how you this is like the stage
so Quentin what inspires the themes that
you put into your music life experiences
I feel like I'm a storyteller yeah I do
like telling stories and pulling from
like people I love and people I know and
and that sort of thing so Quinn should
we check out the song so we see how it's
going
hey let's listen to this side but I
didn't have a mic I didn't have a
overhead so it's gonna be like a real
washy you like a weirdly might indeed
kind of thing
[Music]
that's way more vibrant already I'll
play with the bass though he kept
showing up teaching me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telling you when I recorded the
vocals I recorded them in my backyard
that's why all the birds and everything
no I'm telling you and you hear in the
beginning of the song code yeah oh yeah
that's my neighbor's kid that thing
they're just like plan and see that's
that's really the essence the organic
acids yeah so the fact that you did that
on your in two areas
do you think living in Alaska influences
your music at all yeah I think the
weather influences me in general this is
like so freaking dark for like eight
months you know yeah yeah yeah I think
that affects my writing for sure despite
any musics current dark streak many
artists these days are open about their
own mental health and shed light on
things like depression and anxiety
I've been therapists at a few shows when
I wrote those songs I was playing for
nobody that was true therapy now pouring
my heart out in front of like strangers
and and them just really willing to take
me in is so crazy and I never thought
that would happen in a million years so
it's like I'm really grateful for that
[Music]
Quinn is currently working on his first
full-length album
boy I'm surely gonna sir
my grandma was a saint
[ __ ] up even a quitter never not
why ops you needle in this area
my war is to smile I heard that and
people lost your story do it this shirt
work hard and don't drink
hey keep it open for as long one
I make no mistake
[Music]